the South Pacific nation of Kiribati is
a remote collection of islands scattered
along the equator across a distance the
width of the United States from the
turquoise lagoons you never guess that
these islands were the scene of one of
the bloodiest battles and US Marine
Corps history
today the island nation is being put on
the map again as the first country to be
erased from it people in Kerry bus as
it's known here live just beyond the
Dateline every day they're among the
first to see the sunrise as one of the
world's lowest lying nations they're
also among the first to confront the
impacts of climate change
[Applause]
I buy young one of the outer islands of
Kerry boss has 6,000 residents who live
almost entirely off of the land and sea
our first stop is to boo Kanako back in
the 1970s it was a thriving coastal
village and the site of one of a by
Young's Maine harbors today it looks
like this you can see where the water
started to enter the foundations are all
that's left of the two hundred
households that once lived around this
Cove rising tides have eroded the coasts
and contaminated the fresh water supply
many of Ave Jung's residents have
abandoned their homes and scattered
across the 33 islands of Kerry boss you
see that the poetry that's all of a pipe
it's all of my bananas and Dennis yeah
how does it feel to see it under water
very surprising
are you scared for the rest of that by
young yes this church at manava
or community center were built over a
decade ago today the area has been
abandoned to flooding but the people of
taboo Kanako hope to preserve these two
structures the people in the side of the
beguine up of lagoon they'd already gone
to the mainland
because 200 meters of their land
disappear and the people I lived there
remove and remove a separately right now
we're experiencing total inundation of
areas that previously were not
vulnerable to normal tides and we're
getting something that we call king
tides which are actually extreme high
tides these were non-existent even when
I was a young boy Andrew team is the
president's senior advisor on climate
change it's no longer a question of if
we will who will remain in the country
it's a matter when we will have to leave
because the science is actually very
clean so what is the science saying the
basic physics of climate change is very
clear and very simple if the whole ocean
expands and if the erosion increases in
temperature the volume will expand the
other part of the story is that if the
whole ice in the bottom northern the
southern and the mountain areas actually
melt all that volume of ice will end up
as water in the oceans sorry this
actually turns out to be true then maybe
we wouldn't have more than the rest of
this century to stay here what is the
government doing right now for each
Erebus people who are affected by
climate change we need to start worrying
about what happens to the total
population women whether they go how
will they settle down will they be
treated as refugees can they be treated
as refugees kiri bus president anote a
Tong has lobbied for binding
international treaties to cut carbon
emissions for over a decade he's grown
impatient with the lack of urgency he's
seen from industrialized nations as the
tides continue to rise on his home
that's a global community we need to
talk about carbon emission levels when
they talk about temperature rises but in
fact what will be achieved once those
agreements are reached is of no
consequence to our situation because we
are already being impacted and will
continue to be impacted
whatever the agreements reached at the
international level why is this
something that's personal to you not as
the president of carapace but as a
family man I have children I have a lot
of grandchildren with this and areas
being put forward by the climate
scientists I think there is real danger
in their future if nothing is done to
raise the level of the islands above the
rising seas then the reality would be
that we have to relocate up and so we
are preparing for that tong is one of
the world's first presidents forced to
plan the gradual demise of his country
due to climate change
faced with the need to move its people
in masse the government of Cuba is
sending citizens abroad to Australia and
New Zealand for job and skills train
preparing them for when they'll have to
leave for good they call the effort
migration with dignity I wouldn't want
to migrate and be classified as a
refugee anyway
I really prefer to move to an area where
I can settle down and neck like anybody
else in that society only the refugee
government of the people have definitely
come forward to say yes we will assist
kilobase if ever there is reason for
them to relocate no other nation no
other country has ever come forward with
that just a few miles from the Curia bas
Parliament the village of 8oz stands
amidst an ever-rising swamp residents
fear it may soon face the same fate as
the underwater villages of a bay on the
home of fifteen-year-old Roop a was once
an oceanside sanctuary until more
frequent king tides engulfed the
property now her family lives in a
perpetual state of construction building
and rebuilding sea walls to fortify
their children and livelihoods if you
were called earlier there were about 20
meters of beach here and some of who
faced family members building a wall now
there's about two meters worth of water
and flooding in some of the areas just
behind the wall Ruby's family hopes to
send her overseas for a better life
where are we good best okay but where
will you go in New Zealand
they haven't been selected for the
government's migration with dignity
program so they're making their own
arrangements
yanti da she's trying to find a way
through the immigration in the adoption
yes so that you can live with it
in New Zealand are you excited yeah
excited I said what are you sad about
missing hear about missing our places
musing of foreign friends Ruby's
grandmother fears for the family's
future here in eight ah we have tried to
build up the seawall many times are
still broken as climate change forces
families to relocate nearly half the
country's population has moved to the
nation's capital island of South Tarawa
this mass migration has made it one of
the most populated areas on earth with a
density similar to that of Tokyo or Gaza
the overcrowding has caused other
problems like pollution disease and poor
sanitation problems that may further
threaten the freshwater supply it's like
walking through a minefield here the
rising tide isn't just bringing water
it's also bringing tons and tons of
trash that combined with thousands of
people who are moving to higher ground
is threatening the little bit of land
that's still left we already had our
development was challenges waste
disposal solid waste disposal is a
problem the utilities are stressed and
so we have all of that and this is being
compounded by the fact that we have to
attend to the challenges of climate
change tomato is one of the most
vulnerable sites in South Tarawa it's
also just a few short miles from the
island's primary freshwater aquifer a
single wave across this thin strip of
land could leave the water supply
contaminated for up to two years
places them get better by seawater every
high tide see that many sea walls that
they have bet from the different times
that the tide has come to wash them away
and they keep building rebuilding and
rebuilding colonies a Lofa is a
community organizer who helps Pacific
Islanders deal with the impact of the
rising seen much of her focus is on the
over 60% of the Kerry boss population
under 30 these young people could be the
last generation to live on these islands
to know that they used to come from a
very beautiful country now in the world
we've got a big they got the most
beautiful ocean you know if wherever
they go they will never have this kind
of ocean anymore they will never have
that connection with their people with
their land that they used to have four
Paolini say the current threat of
displacement has an element of deja vu
her family is from the Kerry bass island
of banaba where in the 1940s residents
were forcibly relocated to Fiji by a
British mining company we lost touch of
the island our ayman incurable because
the company took over when they just
mined almost everything away for an
indigenous person you always have that
spiritual connection gl and and the
connection really is through your
ancestors they come up with the stories
the stories of who we are as Akira bus
people right from the beginning how
would you feel if you had to leave your
ancestors here in canvas I do not want
anyone ever to experience you know
forced migration because we were
actually forced to leave and I do not
want anyone because of climate change to
leave their country despite the
challenges the Cuba's people are finding
ways to resist their fate we plan Negros
who protect our coasts our land you see
when you plant these kind of mangroves
they are like wave breakers how long
does it take to grow a few weeks
no is that very new roots mangrove trees
can grow in salty water and are an
affordable way for communities to
preserve their coastline
and so it's protecting this end from
erosion we said it's a seed when it
falls it falls this way actually and so
that's why they grow see all this one is
a fall from this and it just it's stuck
in the soil and grow so what we do we
just go in and collect all this and
distributed among our youth and we start
planting three at a time
Laureen and Turanga are determined to
save their school and their Island
Laureen began to research her school's
receding coastline when she noticed that
the beach used to play on was quickly
disappearing so you guys are very
focused on collecting the evidence that
proves I mentioned yes not believe that
the walls but only the trees and the
stands whether we can know whether the
studies
walked away but without international
support they know that their efforts
will not be enough the outer country
some they have bigger batteries than us
yeah that's actually it's actually also
contributing to the furniture so we like
to either go a helping hand to the
because range together yeah I tried
together in cooperating
as you can understand my greatest
concern was for my people if it is to be
the future of our young people in the
early stages my answer would have been
nothing there is nothing we can do it's
beyond our control but I couldn't accept
that because it's not good enough we got
to come forward with innovative
solutions as a country without industry
Cerebus has no carbon emissions to cut
what they do have is tuna and in an
effort to set an example for
industrialized nations president Tong
launched the Phoenix island protected
area or PIPA a marine reserve that would
secure the world's tuna supply for
future generations we thought that we
would do this as part of our statement
to the international community that yes
all nations have to make sacrifices in
order to address the issue of climate
change no matter how desperately we need
the revenue from this nevertheless it is
our contribution
yet despite their willingness to
sacrifice neither the people of kerry
bus nor their government have the
leverage to change the country's fate in
2015 the international community will
convene at the UN climate summit in
Paris it is hoped that they will set
binding targets for countries to cut
carbon emissions an agreement that won't
be implemented until 2020 for low-lying
island nations these measures will be
too little too late
climate change even if its impact
Scarabus right now and is undermining
our development and all that it's not a
bad Carabas alone it's about the whole
world
here we are testing the human values how
do people respond when they find out as
in the situation like this and we may be
on the front line going down for us it
will reach everyone in right in the end
[Music]
you